so
i um
i need to tell you guys a secret
[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen today's video is
sponsored by squarespace and i'm going
to take you on a little vlog of my
recent family trip to prince edward
island now before i do i of course want
to share a disclaimer that i will be
talking about disordered eating so feel
free to skip this if it's not supportive
to your journey and i also want to flag
that i acknowledge my immense privilege
being able to take a holiday and that i
have a flexible enough work situation to
do just that and of course a reminder if
you're new here to subscribe to this
channel and ring that bell so that you
never miss out also a quick note about
my sponsor squarespace which i know that
you've heard me talk about a lot before
i'm really just such a huge fan of how
easy they make this whole
entrepreneurial life so in addition to
everything that i do here on youtube i
also coach a lot of dietitians who want
to learn about how to blog and make
videos and social media posts and so
many of them struggle with this whole
website thing i get it it can feel like
such a huge huge beast if you're really
not that tech savvy and i'm not but
squarespace is a super intuitive
all-in-one platform that makes it so
easy for anyone to set up a website blog
or online store regardless of your niche
now one of the features that i really
like is their donation feature so you
can encourage people to support a cause
of your choice on your site by easily
gathering payments online you can also
set up members only content and can
communicate easily with your members
through their email list programs
honestly just so nice when the
technology just works because i feel
like i otherwise struggle way too much
with this so if you're interested in
getting started you can check out
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain so
i need to tell you guys a secret um i'm
not doing well i'm not sure if it's like
the impending doom of another wave of
covet or the hormonal roller coaster of
pregnancy and breastfeeding and weaning
or maybe it's just like the fact that
i'm trying to come to terms with the
idea that i might want to start
medicating for my anxiety and insomnia
but
like i'm fully burning out i'm just
finding like i'm having a hard time
finding joy or things to look forward to
and my sleep gets better only to get way
worse and i'm also finding that i'm like
falling into some of my mild ocd like
coping mechanisms anytime that i'm
feeling stressed and all of this to me
feels like a really big red flag but
thankfully like just based on my
experience i know how to catch these
things before they get out of control so
i feel like i know myself really well
and i know when even like a little
whisper of an intrusive disordered
eating thought starts to kind of creep
into my head that there's generally a
bigger issue that i need to address like
it's never about the food but i guess
that leads me to need to tell you
the honest truth that for a lot of us
eating disorders don't necessarily just
go away for me i know that controlling
my food was a coping mechanism that i
relied on for so many years to help me
manage my anxiety and of course now
looking back i know that that was like a
band-aid and a really really one of that
and these days you know i've largely
made peace with food which i'm very
proud of of course but i sometimes rely
on other problematic coping strategies
particularly around my sleep and you
know that's something that i still have
to work on in the meantime i do think
i'm pretty quick to identify and call
out when any like little disordered
eating ninja tries to sneak into my
brain
[Music]
and try to convince me that skipping
breakfast will make the discomfort of my
anxiety go away the reality is i have to
fight these types of battles every day
and usually i win you know like at 33
years old i think i have a really
healthy relationship with food
i'm not even sorry but when i'm really
in the trenches with work and i'm not
sleeping and i'm not particularly
motivated by life or like i'm just
feeling worn down just trying to fight
my own demons
i
just feel like i need to escape i need
to get out and that was why we planned
an impromptu trip to prince edward
island let me take you with me on our
little family trip and i'm going to add
some little food freedom learnings in
there along the way so cancel my calls
reschedule my appointments i need off
the grid and out of the grind it's time
for
a little bit of a reset love that
journey for me
this is the most idyllic place on earth
prince edward island now before kids
this would have been like snoresville to
me i would probably have zero interest
in a place with no designer shopping no
five-star restaurants no excitement but
now
when i so badly just need to get off the
hamster wheel and reset it is literally
my heaven
on earth yes the internet is too slow to
watch a full youtube video and any
incoming calls go to voicemail because
the reception sucks so much and i'm not
even sure there's like a starbucks on
the whole island never mind close by but
here in this little simple cottage by
the water i feel safe i can move at like
a slower simpler pace where decision
fatigue doesn't paralyze me every single
day so this family vacation was like the
mini pause button that i needed so badly
to help me gain better perspective on
what actually matters in my life and
because my mental health was being taken
care of here it was way easier for me to
treat my body well and feel great
physically too so how did i get here
well here are some of my tips to use my
holiday reset strategy whether you're
out of the office or you're still in the
grind
cheers
it's a good one tip one let go of
routine i am a type a perfectionist so
you know your girl loves a good routine
but if the routine isn't serving you we
gotta nip that in the bud what i mean is
that if you're struggling with
disordered eating or exercise thoughts
that are typically pacified by a
specific routine or set of rules that
make you feel safe it's really time to
challenge this and switch it up push
yourself outside of your comfort zone so
a holiday when you're actually
physically taken out of your routine and
any kind of triggers for your routine is
an obvious way to do this but i totally
acknowledge that we can't just all take
a holiday whenever we want sometimes it
can be as simple as changing or
switching up just one little habit a day
that kind of sets you off on destructive
behaviors for the rest of the day for
example if you habitually intermittent
fast until noon as some kind of rule
even though maybe it doesn't feel good
to you maybe try to have breakfast a few
days a week just to start or if you
always have to have green juice or lemon
water first thing in the morning see
what happens when you don't challenging
some of these habits might help you see
that nothing terrible happens if you
don't do them every day my time in pei
was just reorienting in so many ways and
that forced reorientation really helped
me surrender control so that i could
remind myself about the things that
actually bring me joy so tip number two
is to enjoy the experience and make
memories through food no one ever looked
back at their holiday five years down
the road and thought oh i wish i didn't
eat that buttery lobster roll but i
think if i spent the entire week
obsessing over the fact that most of
these little mod pop chip shops don't
have side salad i would have felt a true
longing and regret i would have been
missing out on real life and family
memories if i brought my kid an ice
cream cone and sat in the car wishing
that i had my own this is particularly
important to me as a parent since i want
my boys to have pleasurable
relationships with food so one rainy day
for example i even decided it'd be nice
for us to bake some cookies together and
i really hope that when he grows up he
remembers these days as fondly as i know
that i remember baking with my mom and
my grandmother now the one and only
thing that i planned for this trip other
than like renting the car and the
cottage was that i made a reservation at
chef michael smith's in at bay fortune
for their big fireworks fees so this was
like our one night out without the kids
and i kind of see it as like the
ultimate pei foodie experience that i
really didn't want to miss if i had the
choice and of course it did not
disappoint we are in the car headed to
our first and only childless evening
tonight
uh we're going to the innabe fortune
which is a lovely restaurant and inn run
by chef michael smith and if you're
canadian i actually don't know if
american food number has chef michael
smith's shows but he is one of the og
food network celebrities here in canada
and i've met him several times i've
worked with him on a few projects he's
lovely so we're really looking forward
to tonight we've actually been to the
inn before for dinner and it was a
really fun
experience so
this is kind of one of those really
quintessential foodie experiences if you
can come out to the pei
definitely try to get a reservation at
their fire feast
you'll see lots of clips from some of
the food we get to enjoy later on
but it is teeming rain outside i don't
know if you can see but we're getting
the tail end of a hurricane and
i blue dried my hair not sure why
because you know what's gonna happen by
the end of this evening
but you know after a few cocktails a few
glasses of wine not sure i'm gonna care
uh yeah all right let's get to it
magic
[Music]
[Music]
tip number three is to enjoy the
experience and make memories not about
food food is integral to the social and
familial fabric of our lives but it
doesn't have to be everything i have to
say that when i was really struggling
with my relationship with food i used to
plan pretty much all of our trips and
everything we did around meals nothing
else mattered in our day beyond where we
were eating and what we were eating and
i basically just kind of justified this
behavior because i called myself a
foodie now i still do think that i'm a
foodie food is still a huge huge part of
my life and i love to eat but it's not
everything and it's not the only tool in
my toolbox and true food freedom to me
was getting to a place where like a meal
schedule or a reservation didn't run my
life we could take a day trip into town
and have no clue where what or when we
would eat but that we would just like
figure it out whenever we got hungry so
once we stumbled upon a really cute
family orchard on the way home from a
day trip and we picked up like the most
unplanned yet delicious snack of life
and we made so many fun memories doing
it another time we found this really
cute petting zoo where we fed alpacas
and other little miniature animals not
ourselves and then of course there were
most days where the weather was just so
beautiful we would lose track of time
just running around the beach and
building sand castles until somebody
started to get a little cranky because
it had been a few hours since we last
had a meal a decade ago i wouldn't have
been able to just not have a plan for
every single meal on a trip
take a look at this and having this
flexibility was just so so freeing that
brings me to tip number four ask
yourself every day what do i actually
want to eat if nothing is off limit back
in my disordered eating days i would
pack so many forbidden foods into my
holiday meals because i knew i'd have to
soon come home and then be back on my
diet the result would be that i would
end up eating a lot of super heavy rich
foods morning noon and night every
single day even if i wasn't even in the
mood for them i'd feel totally tapped
out but i felt like i had to i had no
choice i would basically just be going
through the motions of a binge just
because i knew that i had to get the bad
foods in while i could but here in pei
we would often get some kind of fried
fish or like a lobster roll for lunch
and it would always come with fries but
after having like a piece of battered
fish or really buttery lobster roll i
often wouldn't even want more than a few
fries now i know that this takes a lot
of practice but i've realized that a
handful of fries a few times a week
tastes so much better than a mountain of
fries once a week ditto for dessert
alcohol and even stereotypically
quote-unquote healthy foods as well
moderation and variety will always yield
the most physically and emotionally
satisfying experience moving on to tip 5
when you make a food choice ask yourself
how does this food make me feel so my
approach to food on a holiday today is
so different than it was 10 years ago
when i was really struggling with food i
would restrict really heavily leading up
to kind of a holiday so that i could
binge on all of these heavy over-the-top
meals breakfast lunch and dinner seven
days a week only to get home and feel
really unwell physically and also
riddled with guilt emotionally which of
course would just then start the cycle
all over again and it wouldn't be hard
for me to let my anxiety push me back
into that same cycle again sure i
probably ate more fried foods than i
normally do but i actually felt really
great physically because
i never felt the need to overeat if i
ate fish and chips for lunch i would
naturally choose some kind of steamed
seafood with like a salad and some corn
for dinner at home it was never an
intentional oh i had a cheat meal now i
need to eat super clean it was truly
just an intuitive way to eat and feel my
body ditto after my one big meal at the
inn
so last night was so much fun first of
all just nice to talk to other human
beings which we haven't gotten a lot of
exposure to in ontario um and also just
like an amazing experience they did a
farm tour and the farm is amazing then
like a little oyster hour and they have
tacos and cocktails and we had so much
fun and honestly i was talking to my
husband afterwards i was like that was
so awesome
and so much food like we had all the
kind of hors d'oeuvres and then the sit
down multi-course meal
and i was thinking and talking to him
and i was like do you remember the time
when we were like 10 years younger and
we used to do like back-to-back tasting
menus with wine pairings when we
traveled
now i'm like
just give me like i just want a fruit
salad for breakfast after that because i
still felt quite satisfied when i woke
up um but the beautiful thing about food
freedom is that i was able to listen to
my body and not like force myself
through finishing a course when i just
like wasn't for it though i will say i
did eat the entire dessert course
because hey we got a second stomach for
dessert right um but by the time that
the main came around i maybe ate like
maybe a third of it as delicious as it
was i just
couldn't put it back and i lost my
appetite and i was able to just kind of
say i'll take this home for the kids and
that's exactly what we did but anyways
it was a fantastic experience if you're
ever in pei that is absolutely something
that you want to book ahead on they book
way in advance
so definitely take the time to look that
up in at bay fortune with chef michael
smith and try to get in their books oh
i'm sad that this holiday is ending
but alas
all good things have to come to an end
and i need to get back to work so
tis life
now obviously this takes practice and
time to really be able to trust
ourselves not to overeat especially if
you're used to restricting all of your
adult life but remind yourself tomorrow
is another delicious day there's no need
to eat to the point of discomfort when
your body trusts itself that there's
something delicious to be had again
really soon and finally tip number six
embrace the ena i think this has been
the hardest thing for me to learn
because you know relaxing or being
enough or doing the bare minimum doesn't
come easy to me i'm a type a
perfectionist people pleaser so there's
always something that i feel that i need
to do now at times in my life this has
bled into my relationship with food
exercise and my body and i'm always
going to have to work to challenge this
desire to do more but your body and mind
need rest
my body and my mind needs rest and
nothing bad is going to happen if we
take it so what i might not eat as many
vegetables and my workouts might not be
as intense while i'm on vacation but the
point is that i'm gonna do what feels
good to me and what is easily accessible
to me because that's probably a lot much
healthier thing to do than to obsess
over getting my heart rate up or getting
in a certain number of steps on my
holiday for me i know that starting my
day with a little bit of movement makes
me feel good no matter where i am now at
home i have a pretty extensive at-home
gym set up with like a treadmill and
free weights and a functional cables
machine here
i had a floor with a beach towel and it
probably was like 45 minutes away to the
nearest public gym so that was not even
an option so i brought a few easy
lightweight pieces of equipment just for
general stretching and some basic
exercises to help with my diastasis
recti and to just like give me that me
time in the day without letting it get
in the way of other fun things that we
had planned i try to move my body in
ways that feels good and it does feel
good for me to try to move my body every
day um so if i can fit it in great if i
can't it's not the end of the world
things like walking on the beach and
chasing after my kids was really the
main activity that i did most days and i
didn't freak out and only eat salad on
the rainy days that we spent mainly
indoors or in the car and you know what
nothing bad happened i didn't come home
completely deconditioned because of it i
actually felt better in tune with my
body and what felt good to it because
again there was no expectation there was
no routine no noise just an open space
for me to tune in and listen to my
desire to maybe like go for an early
sunrise walk or have the energy to fully
invest in family time it was bliss now
listen i know that we can't all just
take a vacation anytime we have a
stressful week at work
this is actually my first actual
vacation that i've taken since before i
had kids like i didn't even take a mat
leaf with either kid not that anything
about a mat leaf is like a relaxing
holiday trust me but anyways i'm just
saying i've never
really taken the time to slow down and
while i'm often around with my kids i
usually feel a lot of guilt that i'm
just not present nearly enough and as a
result my mental health definitely
suffers i don't know maybe you guys can
relate so if you're finding your
day-to-day grind is causing stress that
triggers your urge to control maybe some
of these little tips can actually help i
know that i'm going to be using them a
lot myself as i try to manage my own
mental health struggles as we enter
another uncertain unfortunate season of
coveted life but on that note that is
all that i have for you guys today so
thank you again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video if you liked it be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below if you want to see more
vloggy stuff if you have any fun topics
you want me to cover things you want me
to talk about let me know and of course
i'll see you again next time on abby's
kitchen
bye